white screen pass is a great feature for
the age of digital libraries
the new movies anywhere feature is the
digital way of lending your movies to
friends
screen pass allows you to send a screen
pass for an eligible title in your own
collection to let a friend
watch that movie for a limited time at
no additional cost
to be eligible to send a screen pass all
you need to do is purchase a movies
anywhere eligible movie from a connected
participating digital retailer
or redeem a non-promotional digital code
every 6 months to utilize your screen
pass
first you find the screen pass eligible
movie in your collection
click the screen pass button and then
follow the steps to send a screen pass
to a friend who will have 7 days to
accept the pass
you get 3 passes per month and if a pass
isn't used it's returned and can be used
again
in the same months it's as simple as
sending a text message
there are almost 7 000 screen pass
eligible movies available on movies
anywhere
80 percent of movies anywhere movies are
screen pass
eligible users can find their eligible
movies on their my movies page
in the my eligible screen pass movie
slider
once the screen pass is sent you can
watch together
even when you're apart and enjoy a
co-viewing experience of the movie
for a better way to share your love of
movies make your way over to movies
anywhere dot com
your movies together at last you must
also be 13 years
or older to sign up for movies anywhere